how well do you know the man who brought
Napoleon Dynamite's Pedro to life it
turns out that nowadays he's living
exactly the way he wants to as an actor
producer musician and reality TV star
let's take a look at where ether and
ramirez's many skills have taken him
Ramirez Wears many hats but it seems
that his DJ one might be his favorite
he's traveled the globe in this capacity
performing at all kinds of private
parties festivals and public gatherings
his prowess as a DJ an entertainer is
also aided by his wide and varied
repertoire which includes everything
from frothy disco favorites to grinding
electronica believe it or not his music
career actually predates his film career
nocturnal rampage a collective of
musicians he co-founded began in 2000
and has a long history of throwing raves
and parties based in Austin Texas
his original mixes are available on
YouTube and are well worth a look in
from fans and Napoleon new visa light
Ramirez isn't just a devotee of digital
sound however he's also an accomplished
player of more than a few traditional
instruments though he's been known to
play the violin and use his voice for
everything from rock ballets to rap he's
perhaps best known as a harmonica player
and is often eager to bust it out for an
impromptu jam session no matter where he
may be
Ramirez always seems ready to throw down
the musical gauntlet as he started so
early appearing in such 90s jams as
Kazaam and Tammy and the t-rex it's no
surprise that he's so comfortable
switching it up as a performer his
mother had a hand in that putting him in
performing arts classes from a very
young age a practice he later continued
in order to expand his social life it's
hard to remember nowadays how unlikely a
hit Napoleon Dynamite was an oddly
deadpan protagonist with a hairstyle at
least 20 years out of date joke centered
around Jamiroquai obscure tiger lion
hybrids and tater tots it's a movie that
could only have come out of the
independent film scene undeniably fresh
without visible efforts perfectly
bizarre without ever feeling calculated
and above all else indefinable addictive
it's no surprise then that Ramirez has
continued to keep at least one foot in
the world of indie movies since his turn
is Pedro he starred in everything from
short films like tomorrow's yesterday to
serie
biopic such as endgame but he's not too
proud to show up in some good
old-fashioned popcorn blockbusters
either with action thriller crank and
goofy comedy Employee of the Month as
notable additions to his filmography
Ramirez seems to be an actor who keeps
his eyes on the stars without ever
forgetting where it came from
name an actor who's gained an ounce of
fame and you'll name a collector of some
kind year MO del Toro has a house full
of horror paraphernalia Nick Cage is so
devoted to Superman that he named his
son after the Man of Steel himself ypres
and Ramirez meanwhile is devoted to cars
so much so that it long predates his
fame in an interview with Motor Trend
Ramirez set out his long-held interest
in participation in the California
racing scene he started with a
Frankenstein car one bequeathed to him
by an older brother that contained more
pieces from other cars than its original
body though it wasn't much to look at it
was the first of what eventually became
a vast collection he went on to note
that his love of speed doesn't just
confine itself to cars he also loves to
throw his mountain bike in the trunk and
take it wherever he can cycle freely you
ever take it off any sweet jumps actors
in this day and age often find it
advantageous to diversify their audience
it's not enough to appeal to only the
rarefied indie connoisseur the excitable
fanboy or the swooning rom-com fee nor
is it enough to stick to only one screen
large or small and with the growing
prestige of channels like HBO and
Showtime there's no shame in television
any longer
yet even within the small sphere of
television may be sticking to one genre
or format isn't enough Ramirez having
conquered the worlds of indie film
action beat-em-ups HBO animation and
more has also dabbled in reality TV and
appeared to have great fun doing it his
most notable appearance was as a judge
on cycle 8 of America's Next Top Model
on which he Foster and and assessed the
contestants performances during an
acting challenge appropriately enough
the episode was entitled the girl who
impresses Pedro Ramirez doesn't seem
particularly content to sit on the
sidelines of his career nor to rest on
his laurels and only one type of job in
2006 is Employee of the Month he
laid a limp spined box boy you're the
lowest of the low yeah and lowest of the
low
aren't you a box boy - Jorge oh yeah but
he's my box boy
yeah I'm a hit box boy he followed that
up with a role in 2012's Casa de me
Padre a ludicrously over-the-top parody
of Latin soap operas then he was a
janitor in 2016's middle school the
worst years of my life
all of this however stands in stark
contrast to his boldest move yet
founding his own production company
powerhouse Pictures Entertainment is a
joint project with Chris Barrett a
director producer and author a company
which aims to produce across various
platforms and media powerhouse has long
been affiliated with after-school a
documentary exploring the story of
Deborah LaFave the American teacher who
was arrested in 2005 for lewd and
lascivious battery of one of her 14 year
old students clearly Ramirez is looking
to spend more time behind the camera as
he moves on to the next phase of his
quirky career check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]